CBS this morning bad weather is
threatening to dampen the holiday spirit
on the first full day of Hanukkah in
just two days before Christmas there are
big storms in the West and the southeast
this morning that's bad news for a
record number of more than 115 million
Americans expected to travel by car
train or plane over the holidays rain
and flash flooding in South Florida shut
down Fort Lauderdale Hollywood Airport
overnight one traveler told us driving
through the flooding was like looking
out a boat cabin window unbelievable so
the TSA estimates 42 million people will
pass through its security checkpoints
over the holidays nearly four percent
more than last year
Lola lanky is at Newark Liberty
International Airport in New Jersey
molla what are you seeing there
well good morning guys you know the
worst part that we've seen so far is the
traffic getting to the airport once
you're in here once you're in the
terminal you know despite how it looks
looks pretty busy things are running
pretty smoothly of course that is just
here at Newark that is Airport specific
but if you're out in California or in
the southeast part of the country as you
mentioned those incoming storms could
cause some major delays as millions of
people across the country travel for the
holidays implement weather is being
blamed for this nearly 70 car pileup on
Interstate 64 near Williamsburg Virginia
on Sunday fog and icy road conditions
were causative factors in this multi
vehicle crash no deaths were reported
but more than 50 people were injured and
it took crews hours to clear the highway
in California another crash caused an
internet outage that contributed to more
than 140 flight delays at Sacramento
International Airport impacting
thousands of passengers during one of
the busiest travel weekend's of the year
it's frustrating lines forever I've been
here for an hour and I haven't even got
up there to check my bag yet according
to estimates from triple-a more than 104
million holiday travelers will drive to
their destinations and the day after
Christmas will bring the worst delays
with commutes nearly two times longer
than usual bumper-to-bumper traffic has
become the norm at Los Angeles
International Airport where drivers say
it can take up to two
hours just to go to miles that was it
helped when an electrical problem caused
three empty buses to catch fire there
Saturday night fortunately no one was
injured
point is you know just be prepared be a
bit patient because there's a lot you
know when you show up at an airport
during this time of year
I mean it's there's a lot of traffic and
then just a lot more people move lax is
any example being prepared simply means
just giving yourself more time than you
normally would during this holiday
season here at Newark they're expecting
to serve about two million holiday
travelers this season and already this
morning Vlad we've seen about a hundred
and fifty domestic flight delays all
right MOA thank you very much
you